bon joyeus on est obligé d'en parler
vous aviez chanté pour la victoire de
François Hollande en 2012 et vous
remarquerez quand on chante pour la
gauche même si elle est nulle et bah
c'est quand même moins d'emmerde que
quand on chante pour la droite on fait
un gros bisou à Faudel et Enrico Macias
et maintenant j'accueille mon stagiaire
Tom villa je
t'emmène merde je t'emmerde
tous les calculs je voulais qu'on je
reste concret direct c'est la guerre
sous les bras
mais c'est toi qui a choisi ça non
tu es le Chameroy de cette émission
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire vous voulez que je prenne
du recul c'est ça non
bonsoir à tous et Louis pleinel et lui
c'est le moustachu le plus célèbre des
journalistes politiques avec l'autre qui
bosse sur LCI Arlette Chabot et
non mais alors Edwig j'ai appris que
vous aviez passé votre jeunesse en
Algérie ce qui explique cette moustache
de chanteurs de rails
chept Plenel non mais Edwige il y a pas
que la moustache moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup chez lui c'est votre petit
regard malicieux et le problème c'est
que du coup quand il sourit on sait
jamais si c'est parce qu'il est content
ou parce qu'il a un dossier sur toi
c'est le fondateur de Mediapart alors
Mediapart c'est le journal qui sort des
dossiers sur tout le monde l'affaire est
en cours c'est eux la faire Cahuzac bon
Hanouna c'est pas eux mais ça aurait pu
ça aurait pu c'est vrai d'ailleurs vu
que c'est la grande mode de faire des
des dossiers sur les coulisses des
émissions faites un truc sur Salut les
Terriens
en vrai il est super sympa dans sa loge
il y a énormément de peluches on se
croient au Disney Store les gréements de
fortune Thierry il aura retiré leur
passeport c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
bloqués là
on se voit après on se voit après
[Applaudissements]
Christophe Dugarry Christophe je l'adore
c'est quand même la preuve vivante qu'un
joueur moyen peut devenir un excellent
consultant mais non
[Applaudissements]
nous on
A de la France Télé ils ont Xavier
Gravelaine joueur moyen et consultant
pourri donc c'est quand même merci
98 Siri j'avais 9 ans et je sais pas si
moi je collectionnais les points sur les
pots de Nutella et du coup j'avais la
médaille de Zidane j'avais les le sac à
dos Didier Deschamps et j'avais les
crampons en bois de Christophe et
non mais attends moi Christophe
sincèrement je l'aime beaucoup et puis
c'est une autre génération tout le monde
dit aujourd'hui le joueur de foot il
parle mal français mais bon à la limite
c'est pas grave on leur demande juste de
jouer moi le seul truc qui m'inquiète
c'est que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
seront dans 20 ans les consultants de
demain la gueule des analyses de match
ça va être sous-titré les jeunes dans
sport études il y a étude aussi il faut
pas l'oublier
[Applaudissements]
Joyce Jonathan c'est la classe on dirait
qu'elle sort d'un dessin animé Joyce non
mais c'est vrai la petite sœur de
Blanche-Neige et de Cendrillon tiens moi
je vous imagine le matin c'est des
oiseaux qui vous lavent le dos il y a
des souris qui vous habitent alors vous
parlez le mandarin Joyce ça c'est la
classe gros marché le marché asiatique
pour les Français c'est impressionnant
puisqu'il y a de bien c'est que par les
mandarins c'est pratique parce qu'on
reste au chinois tu peux donner les
vrais noms des plats et pas seulement
les numéros
c'est vrai que c'est pratique
bon joyeus on est obligé d'en parler
vous aviez chanté pour la victoire de
François Hollande en 2012 et vous
remarquerez quand on chante pour la
gauche même si elle est nulle et bah
c'est quand même moins d'emmerde que
quand on chante pour la droite on fait
un gros bisou à Faudel et Enrico Macias
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Joyce on vous a vu dans Plus Belle La
Vie vous avez joué votre propre rôle
c'est vrai qu'ils vous ont fait quand
même passer un casting pour jouer votre
propre rôle c'est des conneries
Christophe moi j'ai une question vous
êtes toujours bronzé comment comment
vous faites parce qu'honnêtement c'est
pas en allant la voir des matchs à Metz
et à quand que vous avez ce temps là
alors je te ferai remarquer je n'avais
pas à Metz ni à quand faire les matchs
pour terminer Edwy Plenel vous sortez un
livre intitulé dire nous c'est Franck
Ribéry qui a trouvé le titre ou pas
Thierry bonne émission bon courage
au lieu de chiller comme d'habitude tu
vas rester avec nous ah mais je peux pas
[Applaudissements]
tu vas voir ce que c'est de faire une
émission de télé merci beaucoup
tu peux prendre des notes mon gars c'est
gentil merci beaucoup c'est pour ton
stage ça va et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu